今日もう一度偈を見てください
五十八番目から五十九番目までです
ヤタサンカーラダーナスミン ウッジタスミン マハーパテ パドマン タッタ ジャーエータ スチ ガンダン マノーラマン エワン サンカーラ ブ
ーテース アンダ ブーテー プトゥッジャネー アティローチャティ パンニャーヤ サッマーサン ブッダッササーワコーということで
すごい簡単な意味です
まず簡単に意味を説明します
ヤタサンカーラダーナスミン
サンカーラダーナっていうのはゴミということでね
ゴミの山っていうことですね
ウッジタスミンマハーパテ
マハーパタっていうのは大道というか
大きな道っていうことでね
見事に大きな道っていうのはたくさん人々が行ったり来たりする道っていうことで
だからみんな平気でゴミをポイ捨てするんです
昔のことだから 別にゴミの処理っていうことはあったわけでもないし
また逆にビニール製品はなかったんだからね
ゴミっていうことはないんですよ
そのまま捨てちゃえばいいんです
全て自然なものだからね
ゴミっていうことではありませんですが
人間にとってはゴミはゴミなんですね
そういうことで 大きなもう人々が行ったり来たりしている道
道の側にかなりゴミの山があって
ウッジタスミンっていうのはポイ捨てのこと
マハーパテっていうのは大道
大きな道 そちらにパドマンタッタジャーエータ
パドマンっていうのはハツの花でハツですね
ハツの花 タッタ そこにジャーエータ
生まれてくるということは花が咲いてくる
ゴミの中に スチガンダン
スチっていうのは清らかで
ガンダンっていうのは香りがあって
マノーラマン とても美しいもので
見て楽しいものなんですね
まあ随分簡単なことなんですね
言っているのは ゴミの山で
みんなもう気持ち悪いと捨てたものの中から
美しい香りのあるハツの花が咲いているんだと
五十九番目になってくると意味は
エワンサンカーラブーテース
このようにサンカーラという状態の
というサンカーラっていうのはサンカ
行ですね 全ての現象はサンカーラと言うんですね
組み立てたもの 一時的なものというね
全ての存在も宇宙も 何でもかんでも一時的な
組み立てた 組み立てられた現象ですよ
実体何も意味何もあるわけじゃないんです
だからサンカーラブーテ
この現象の世界でアンダブーテ
知恵がない アンダっていうのは目が見えないというね
盲目というかね 目が見えない
いわゆる知恵のないプトゥッジャネー
一般人の中で アティローチャティパンニャーヤ
アティローチャティっていうのはより輝くというね
例えば夜の空を見ると
星よりは月はより輝くんですね
そういう感じで みんなを抑えて輝く
他の光を パンニャーヤ
知恵で輝くんですね 誰でしょうかというと
サッマーサンブッダッササーワコ
正覚者の弟子たちは 正覚者の弟子たちは無知で目が見えない
この現象である一般人の中で
知恵でもってすごく輝いているんだということ
別にそれだけの意味ですから
あんまりコメントする必要はないと思いますけどね
しかし これはもう作品で
作品というか お釈迦様はすごいすごい知恵で作った偈だから
その文 パーリ語のね 構成やらね
そういうところ見ると
もうかなり苦労しているところは見えると思いますよ
例えばサンカーラダーナという五十八番目の単語がございますね
サンカーラダーナっていうのはゴミということなんです
それで五十九番目にサンカーラブータっていう単語を使っているんですね
だから この仏教の真理を語るために
たとえ話を使ってはいけないんだけど
このたとえ話に入れる単語も
なんとか似ている単語を探して入れておくんですね
だからパーリ語で理解する人にとっては
すごい気分のいい作品になるんですね
サンカーラダーナ 世の中はサンカーラダーナということ
まあゴミの意味ですね
サンカーラブータ 我々もただのサンカーラブータではないかと
ブータっていうのは生命のことでもあるし
もう成り立っているという
サンカーラで成り立っているという
先生 サンカーラの場合ですね KH
という風になると 量とか形勢になります
知らないそんなのは 何でそう書いてるのかと
じゃあ意味は何ですか？日本の訳は
KAのRですとゴミなんですけども KHA
ですと量とか  それだったら逆でしょ
上はサンカーラと書いてますけど
ちょっと待って 注釈書の意味は調べてみます
サンカーラにはしていますけどね
サンカーラはゴミですけど
サンカーラブータ ゴミにしてもいいんだけど
別に まあどっちでも サンカーラにはしていますね
サンカーラサンカーラ
サンカーラッハナスミン
カチャララーシンヒアット
まあ両方もうこちらもゴミだと思ってるんですね
じゃあその方が正しいかも
うんうん まあ両方ゴミにしていますね
ゴミでできている生命にということになりますね
その場合は  [紙をめくる音]では訂正してまた意味を言います
ゴミの山でね 少しハスの花が咲いているような感じで
ゴミにできている人間っていうのは一般人が
ゴミでできている人々の中で
あの少学者の弟子たちは知恵でもってみんなを抑えて輝いているんだという意味になるんです
もう一個すいません はい
三分の二はサーはこうで単数になってるんで
この場合厳密に言うと弟子はという弟子たちじゃなくて
弟子はって単数で  弟子に入れてください
お釈迦様の忠告がありますけど
単語に引っかかったらひどい目にあいますと
単語じゃなくて意味は大事なんです
私は別に大学授業をしているわけじゃないんだからね
これは仏教的な道より真理を語っているだけで
意味しか取りません まあ一応それは単数でも複数でも
まあ一応原文では単数で書いてますけど
意味としてはそういう一般的な意味で
英語でもただ単数のマンというね
あのという単語かという単語をそこはない場合は人類の意味をするんです
あマンと言えば一人の人間で
マンと言えばある確定した人物で
それ取っちゃうと 普通は名詞使わなければ取ってはいけない
英語の場合は しかし わざと取る場合あります
でも使わない場合あるんです
その場合は 使えるのはこのマンとかね
そういう単語いくつかしか使えないんだけどね
例えば雨 レーンと言えますけど
レーンという単語だけ使う場合はとね
そうすると普遍的な雨
特定した目じゃなくて
マンという単語を使った場合も
普遍的な人物ということで
まあそういう これはまあとあの
あんまり派手に使う 分けるということは
単語で分けることはパーリ語はないんですけど
我々の場合でもその意味がしっかりしています
使い方はね その場合は
でも使わないで 単数の少学者の弟子っていうことなんですね
だからでディサイプルでもディサイプルでもなく disciple of the ブッダになるんです
ということで 日本訳するときは複数にしなくちゃいけないんです
日本ではとでの差がありませんだからね
はい まあそれは置いておいて
決してある特定の仏弟子が光り輝いているということを言っているわけじゃないので
他はどうでもいいやという話ではないので
仏弟子はまあ輝いているんだという意味になるんです
まだありますか？文法的な問題は
うん まあサンカーラでとるかサンカーヤでとるかという場合は
解説は変わりますけどね
それでこのハスの花 ゴミの中でっていう場合は
だいたい花は咲くのはこの沼なんですね
ただゴミの山ではハスの花咲くっていうことはないんです
ですから 沼の場合はまたゴミも捨てちゃうとかなり気持ち悪いということになります
自然の沼だったら決して気持ち悪いものではありませんだけど
泥いっぱいあっても これゴミまで捨てちゃうとね
そんなに面白いものではありません
で なんでハスの花例えるかというと
ハスの花っていうのは決まってこの水から泥から上に上がるんですよ
上に上がって咲くんです
それからハスの花にはものすごい
あの 何て言いますかね
気持ちを穏やかな穏やかにする
なんかすごく香りがあるんですよ
ものすごいキツい香りではないんだけど
このハスの花っていうのは自分で香り持ってます
それがなんかすごくなんか気分良くなるんです
で この花の香りっていうのは自然な香りすごいもんですよ
この環境っていうのはすごく綺麗にするんですよ
で 今我々消臭剤いろいろもうかけたりするんですけど
かけた瞬間ではいいんだけど
次もっとひどく臭くなるんです
あれは分解しちゃって
その代わりにこの生の本当に自然の花の香りだったらそうではなくて
本当に環境の悪臭を全部それを壊すんです
また その代わりに新しい臭い香りがするということでもないんです
だから ハスの花には一応そういう力がありまして
ジャスミンもそうなんですけど
ジャスミンの場合は いくら時間経っても経っても経っても
香りだけ消えないという特色なんですね
もう干し花になっても
自分の香りだけは頑固で持っている
それはジャスミンの特色なんです
しかし すごい小さい花なんです
すごく小さい花なんですけど
干し花にしても香りだけは持っているという
どういうカラクリかわからない
だから一番世の中お釈迦様の言葉なんで
世の中で一番香りのある花は何なのかというところで
これはジャスミンだよと
で ハスの花はそんなに香りを持ってるわけじゃないんですけど
もっと穏やかな香りなんですけど
簡単に腐ってしまいますから
ハスの花はね そうすると香りも一緒になくなっちゃいます
で 仏教ではこの悟りやら涅槃やら解脱を象徴する花はもうハスの花なんですね
だからブッダの教えそのものを象徴するときでも
使うのはハスの花なんです
そういうことで 仏教を文化として発展する場合は
いろんな壁画やらいろんなものをね
描いたりする場合は 天井画とかね
かなりハスの花をデザインするんですね
だからハスの花のデザインないお寺っていうのはないぐらい
どこでもそちらそれはしっかりとあるんです
こちらも恐らくハスのないな
これないんだからね  下にはいっぱい描いてますよ
一応お釈迦様が座る場合は
この台座はハスの花なんですね
これはそうじゃないんですけど
あちらのミャンマー人が作った仏像がありますけど
そちらは仏像と一緒に台座持ってますけどね
その場合はハスの花にするんです
日本の仏像もまあそういうことで
一応蓮の花に 蓮の花の上にお釈迦様を作るということを決まってあって
大体弟子たちの仏像を作ったりする場合は
もう一応それは抜けちゃうというかね
そういうことで 一応仏教の世界では
蓮の花は象徴として使う
涅槃解脱を象徴する花になります
なんでそれを決めたかというと
あれが湖の水にも濡れることはなくて
泥には全く関係なく 泥の中から生まれて
泥の中から栄養をとって生まれて
泥とは全然関係ない 全く別な次元で花が咲くんですね
そこで注釈書は その説法では
みんな嫌がりますけどとか
悪臭のある泥の沼っていうのはね
しかし そこの中から咲いてきた蓮の花は
それを取ってみたら 王様の頭のてっぺんにも乗りますよと
だから体飾ったりしますよと
だから花はいかにかっこいいかということになるんです
これは臭い泥の中で生まれたもんだから捨てましょう
気持ち悪いということになりません
[音楽]